oh je me suis fait mettre je sais que mon camion
j'essaie c'est juste là
je vais allumer un feu ici maman phil
doit partir la semaine prochaine et nous avons besoin de quelqu'un
pour surveiller les enfants alors je me demandais
si vous voudriez nous '  j'adore
je n'y vais pas tu y vas c'est ce que je
voulais dire
nous ne voyons pratiquement jamais ses
petits-enfants quatre toute la façon d'élever
ses enfants est un géant dans notre visage
c'est sa génération c'est juste leur façon
que cherchez-vous un marin je  Je vais
t'aider
c'est un présage
qu'est-ce que c'est un présage de malheur imminent
grand-père raconte beaucoup de blagues que tu
n'obtiendras pas que des rires
je me donne mal à la tête nous dirions que
ce sont tes mots
qui ne sont pas mauvais pas mauvais elle ressemble à une
veuve de 12 ans peut-être pas ces mots
voici une image qui ne frappe personne d'autre dans ce
jeu comment était-ce possible qu'ils frappent
jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent sur la base vous  étaient bien dehors
bon oh mon père n'écoute pas
comment est la faute de cet Artie un  Prenez toujours
son âme et pour une bonne raison parce
qu'après que vos enfants ont grandi, votre mari
est celui qui reste,
vous devez façonner Artie, vous savez ce que les
grands-parents sont une deuxième chance, c'est
plutôt bien,
ils sont de super enfants et vous êtes vraiment bien
payé, vous devez  casser ses produits
est pratique si jamais tu parles à ma
petite-fille comme ça encore une fois il ne restera
plus rien de toi mais des cheveux roux
dans un accent est ce camarade clair poussiéreux
Tanya tu as menacé son professeur de violon
sinon ton père et moi nous sommes pliés en
quatre pour  essaie de faire les choses à ta façon
tu ne t'es pas penché du tout oh je suis penché
crois moi
je suis penché viens me chercher ici ne me laisse pas en
rade si jamais je t'ai laissé en rade
quatre fois quand j'étais enfant c'est comme
elle pense que nous sommes des idiots au fait où
est-elle où étais-tu je sais